This is a very densely written
show every detail is so
important, from the design of
the room, to the color palette,
to the hair, to the costume,
the emotionality of what our
characters are going through.
Hey look that's, my
sister right there.
I thought it was a very
complex season for Bradley
her character didn't just touch
on being queer it touched on
family with addiction and how we
all get sucked into that vortex
of an addict's life and
ultimately falling apart
because you have no
power over that.
We're past it now!
Are we? Oh my God that's good
to know I didn't know that we --
Alex don't do this to us!
We're finally in a good place.
One thing that Jen
and I discussed
we wanted to make
sure Chip and Alex
didn't come across that they
were just like siblings
yelling at each other.
We wanted to layer everything
with a deep sense of
dedication and love
and I think honestly
it's been easy cause
I just find Jen to be so
bouyant and she's so alive.
You're okay.
I love the relationship
between Chip and Alex.
Chip is kind of in love with her
and they each see the
relationship a little
differently.
I think Alex she's getting out
beyond her narcissism enough to
understand, she's taken
Chip for granted and he has
always been there for her.
Mitch was... Mitch is a human
being.
Karen was so beautiful
in that scene
and it spoke beautifully
to the moment too that
you are some of the
things that have
happened to you
in your life.
You're not just the
one terrible thing.
He really does have
young children.
It's complex!
We're getting to see in
their eyes, in their faces.
All of the feelings that
they had about Mitch.
And now they have
to reconcile them
because he's
no longer there.
We really see Mia
spilling out all of the
feelings that she has
in the midst of this grief.
I think I knew the real him
and the book doesn't
get the real him.
The real him is dead!
An actor is only successful as
the director she
is able to collaborate with and
Victoria Mahoney,
who directs episode 208 is
an extraordinary collaborator.
That first day I
worked with her,
I just felt I'm
madly in love!
It's like, where have you
been all of our lives?
Knows how to speak
to actors so beautifully.
She was incredible.
GO!
Filming this episode
was such a whirlwind
in an already
intense environment.
Thankfully my character is
always in sneakers,
but I literally had to run.
We were sweating doing that.
We're interrupting with
some breaking news.
Our stories are told through our
characters' points of view.
They're complicated as is life
as is human emotion.
One moment you're happy,
one moment you're
trying to figure out
where do I fit?
How do I get there?
What do I do?